بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
فاننا قد وصلنا
في
قراءتنا ودراستنا لكتاب زاد المعاد
الى ذكر ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
بعد بناء المسجد
عمليه المؤاخاه التي كانت بين المهاجرين
والانصار
وكذلك
سننظر ايضا نظره
سريعه مره اخرى الى بعض اهل الصفه وبعض
احوالهم وفضائلهم
وكذلك ننظر
ونقرا ما
عرضه ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى من
مساله تحويل القبله بعض الحكم في ذلك وما
شابه
يقول
ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
ثم اخى بين المهاجرين والانصار
[Silence]
يقول رحمه الله تعالى ثم اخى بين
المهاجرين والانصار النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم اخى بين المهاجرين
والانصار وكانوا تسعين رجلا
نصفهم من المهاجرين ونصفهم من الانصار على
المواساه
ويتوارثون بعد الموت الى وقعه بدر فلما
نزلت واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض هذا
في كتاب هذا في سوره الانفال
الايه الخاتمه في سوره الانفال كذلك في
سوره الاحزاب
رد التوارث الى الرحم وقيل انه اخى بين
المهاجرين ثانيه واتخذ عليا اخا
هذه مساله
ذكرها بعض المؤرخ بعض المؤرخين
وزعم بعضهم ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اخى بين المسلمين في مكه قبل الهجره
فيذكرون
وهذا قول بعيد والروايات فيها ضعيفه كما
سينبه على ذلك ابن القيم لكن على كل حال
القول
هو ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخى بين
المسلمين في مكه
قبل الهجره ثم كانت عمليه ثانيه
في المؤاخاه في المدينه بين المهاجرين
والانصار هذا قول ضعيف وفيه روايات واهيه
يقول ابن القيم
وقيل انه اخر بين المهاجرين ثانيه واتخذ
عليا اخا والاول اثبت يعني ان المؤاخاه
كانت مره واحده
كانت مره واحده في بدايات اقامته صلى الله
عليه وسلم
الدوله الاسلاميه وفي بدايات ايامه في
المدينه
يقول ابن القيم ولو كان ذلك
لكان حق الناس باخوته الصديق الذي قال فيه
لو كنت متخدا من لو كنت متخذا
من امتي خليلا لاتخذت ابا بكر خليلا ولكن
اخي وصاحبي
يقول وهذه الاخوه وان كانت عامه كما قال
وددت ان قد راينا اخواننا
هذه روايه صحيحه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال لاصحابه يوما وجدت ان قد راينا
اخواننا
قالوا السنا اخوانك قال انتم اصحابي
واخواني قوم ياتون من بعدي يؤمنون بي ولم
يروني اسالوا الله تعالى ان نكون منهم
فللصديق من هذه الاخوه اعلى مراتبها كما
له من الصحبه اعلى مراتبها
يقول
ووادع من
بالمدينه من اليهود وكتب بينه وبينهم
كتابا
وبادر
حبرهم عبد الله بن سلام فدخل في الاسلام
وابا عمتهم الا الكفر وكانوا ثلاث قبائل
قال
والنضير
وقريضه وحاربه الثلاثه
ابن القيم رحمه الله يذكر عده مسائل هنا
المساله الاولى المؤاخه
وهذه المؤاخاه كانت مره واحده في بدايات
ايامه في المدينه
وكانوا تسعين رجلا
45 من المهاجرين اخر بينهم وبين مقابلهم
في العدد من الانصار
وذكر مساله القول بالماخاه
المزعومه في مكه قبل الهجره
وارد هذا القول
وجعله من جمله
الشاذ الضعيف
ثم ذكر ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
مساله
الكتاب الذي جعله بينه وبين اليهود يهود
المدينه
الله عز وجل يقول
ضربت عليهم الذله
اينما ثقفوا
الا بحبل من الله وحبل من الناس اليهود
هذه القبائل الثلاثه اين قاع والنضير
وقريضه
هم اصلا من الشام
جاؤوا الى المدينه
ينتظرون بروز وخروج النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم فيها لان المدينه هي موصوفه لهم في
كتابهم وانه سيكون
نبي من العرب من
ذريه اسماعيل
وانه سيكون في هذه الارض ارض المدينه
فاليهود هذه القبائل الثلاثه
ارادوا ان
يكون هذا النبي منهم
رحلوا الى المدينه استوطنوها
رغبه منهم ان يكون الله سبحانه وتعالى
يبعث النبي فيهم
ولذلك كانوا ينتظرون وكانوا يتوعدون
اعدائهم بخروج هذا النبي
فهم اصلا
هذه ليست ارضهم الاصليه لكن اقاموا فيها
وكانت بينهم وبين العرب بالاخص الاوس
والخزرج
تحالف وكان بينهم تعاقد وكان بينهم تجارات
وما شابه ذلك
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لما وصل
المدينه
وجد الناس على قسمين
القسم الاول من العرب
من عباد الاصنام من المشركين
وهم
هاتان القبيلتان العظيمتان الاوس والخزرج
ووجد ثلاث
قبائل من اليهود
يقول اينقاع والنظير وقريضه
فقام النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بجعل
كتابا وعهدا بينه وبين هذه القبائل
الثلاثه من قبائل اليهود وكلهم نقضوا
العهد كلهم
قين قاع والنظير
وقريضه كلهم نقضوا العهد ولم
يوفوا بعهدهم الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم واكثرهم كفر برسول الله اكثرهم
واما الاوس والخزرج
فامنوا ولم يبقى الا الشيء اليسير عند
وفاه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من العرب
في المدينه ممن لم يسلمه بل اسلموا
ودخل الطائفه الثالثه في النفاق
وهذا اول ما
ظهر النفاق في عهد الاسلام
بعد وقعت بدر بعد ما صار الذي صار بين
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم وعدوه
في بدر
فان الناس خافوا منه صلى الله عليه وسلم
وارادوا ان
يغنموا معه
فدخلوا في الاسلام ظاهرا
وباقوا على كفرهم باطنا
وظهرت
ظاهره النفاق حينئذ
وتجد بعض الناس الذين
لم يدققوا النظر ولم يحرروا الالفاظ في
السيره النبويه وفي اخبار الصحابه
تجدهم يذكرون شيئا من النفاق في مكه انه
كان في شيء من النفاق في مكه فمثلا مقوله
مقوله غير مرضيه
بعضهم يذكر وجدت هذا انا في بعض من كتب في
السيره من المتاخرين من من
الكتاب
الذين يكتبون
ويسمون بالمفكرين
الاسلاميين او تسموا
يعني
المفكرين
والمثقفين وهذه الالفاظ اللي طلعت
بمعنى انه لا هو عالم ولا هو جاهل لكنه
بين بين
فيذكرون مثلا ان شيئا من النفاق كان في
مكه
ويمثلون على ذلك مثلا قصه
حمزه ابن عبد المطلب رضي الله عنه
قصته مشهوره معروفه
حينما اسلم
ذكر بعضهم وهذه روايه صحيحه انه رجع الى
مكه وكان يصطاد
فرجع الى مكه
واخبره الناس باذيه ابي جاهل له للنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
فذهب يبحث عنه فوجده عند الكعبه
وكان معه قوسه
فجاءه وضربه في راسه بالقوس وقال اتاذي من
انا على دينه
فبذلك دخل حمزه رضي الله عنه في الاسلام
بعض من لم يحسن
يقول
هو في هذيك اللحظه حكاها ومش قصدها
يعني حكاها حميه
لكن ما كان قصدها
لكن العرب كانوا جماعه اذا قالوا الشيء
وفوا به وكانوا يقولون
الرجل
اسير كلمته فلذلك قام حمزه بالتعبد
يعني الاسلام ظاهرا حتى القى الله سبحانه
وتعالى الايمان في قلبه هذا كلام باطل وما
في روايه حتى الروايات الموضوعة في هذا
الباب ما تحكي هذا الحكي
بل حمزه رضي الله عنه اسلم
قلبا وقالبا من حين ان نطق بهذه الكلمه
على كل حال النفاق
ظهر في المدينه
لاسباب ماليه وتجاريه
واسباب تتعلق بالحرب وما شابه ذلك
وجميع من اسلم في مكه كان مؤمنا صادقا
وليس لاحد رغبه في ان يسلم في مكه الا من
امن بالله واليوم الاخر لانه كانت الاذيه
قويه وشديده
والمقاطعات وما شابه ذلك
على المسلمين
فالانسان الذي يدخل في الاسلام
انذاك
فانه يؤذى كثيرا من قبل اهله من قبل
القبائل الاخرى
تصير يعني مشاكل فلذلك الله عز وجل
اثنى على الصحابه عامه
واثنى على السابقين الاولين خاصه
لانهم تحملوا اكثر ذلك الاذى في سبيل الله
قبل الهجره
يقول ابن القيم
وكتب بينه وبينهم كتابا يعني بينه وبين
هذه القبائل من اليهود
عنده الاوس والخزرج
كثير منهم اسلم
فهو امن
الضرر من الاوس والخزرج ممن لم يسلم منهم
لان
اخوانهم اولاد عمهم جماعتهم من المسلمين
لكن اليهود هذه القبائل الثلاثه ما دخلوا
في الاسلام الا قليلا
فجعل بينه وبينهم كتابا يعني العهد
والله عز وجل ذكر في هذا في سوره ال عمران
وقال
ضربت عليهم الذله اينما ثقفوا
الا بحبل من الله وحبل من الناس هذا الحبل
الذي من الناس
هي المعاهده التي تكون
والهدنه التي تكون بينهم وبين الناس
لكنهم نقضوا العهد يقول ابن القيم وكانوا
ثلاثه قبائل قينقاع والنضير وقريضه وحاربه
الثلاثه فمن على قين قاع
[Silence]
يذكر هنا مساله دخول عبد الله بن سلام رضي
الله عنه في الاسلام
قصه عجيبه موجوده في صحيح البخاري
ان عبد الله بن سلام كان من علماء وشرفاء
اليهود في المدينه
وسمع
بمقدم رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ووجد
ان الصفات التي يعلمها من كتاب الله من
كتاب موسى
وجدها في محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم فجعل
يفكر كيف يختبر هذا الرجل يتاكد انه فعلا
نبي من الله
فجاء الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
في كما في روايه الامام الترمذي عن ابن
عباس
جاء اليه وساله
ثلاث اسئله
يقول لا يعلم هذه الا نبي مش ممكن اي واحد
ثاني يكون يعلم الاجوبه هذه الا نبي
فساله
عن اول طعام اهل الجنه
وساله
عن الذي حرمه اسرائيل على نفسه من قبل ان
تنزل التوراه كل الطعام كان حلا لبني
اسرائيل الا ما حرم اسرائيل على نفسه من
قبل ان تنزل التوراه
وساله
ما بال الولد يقع الشبه من الام او الاب
ما الذي يكون ما الذي يسبب ذلك فالنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم اجابه
فعبد الله بن سلام لما جاء يساله هذه
الاسئله قال انا اجيبك ان شاء الله لكن
توعدني اذا جاوبتك انك تسلم
فوعده عبد الله بن سلام رضي الله عنه
وعداه ان
اجاب عن هذه الاسئله الثلاثه وهي
كالاختبار
ليتمحص صدق نبواته صلى الله عليه وسلم
فانه يسلم
فاجابه عن هذه الاسئله الثلاثه فدخل عبد
الله بن سلام في الاسلام
وجاء احبار
الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في الوقت
اللي كان عبد الله بن سلام عند الرسول
فما اراد عبد الله بن سلام
ان يعلمهم باسلامه
فكان في
حجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
مخفيا عن اليهود اللي جاؤوا
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم سالهم
ما قولكم في عبد الله بن سلام شو رايكم في
هذا الرجل
فقالوا خيرنا وابن خيرنا
واعلمنا واخذوا
يثنون عليه الثناء العاطر
فخرج عليهم عبد الله بن سلام وقال ها انا
اشهدكم بانني قد امنت بمحمد ودخلت دينه
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وان محمدا رسول
الله
فصاروا يقولوا ايش شرنا وابن شرنا
يعني في لحظه
اثنوا عليه لما سمعوا انه دخل في الاسلام
بدل ما يدخلوا في الاسلام معه اخذوا
يذمونه على حالهم يعني
هذه المؤاخاه التي كانت بين الصحابه
يذكر بعض
المؤرخين اسماء
نقلت الينا
ممن
اخى بينهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
من هؤلاء
المذكورين ابو بكر الصديق
اخر بينه وبين خارج ابن زهير
وعمر بن الخطاب وعتبان بن مالك
وابو عبيده بن الجراح وسعد بن معاذ
وعبد الرحمن بن عوف وسعد بن الربيع
والزبير بن العوام وسلامه ابن سلامه ابن
وقش
وطلحه ابن عبيد الله
وكعب بن مالك
وسعيد ابن زيد وابي بن كعب
ومصعب ابن عمير وابو ايوب خالد ابن زيد
وابو حذيفه
ابن عتبه ابن ربيعه
وعباد ابن بشر ابن وقش وعمار بن ياسر
وحذيفه ابن اليمان وابو ذر الغفاري
والمنذر بن عمرو وحاطب بن ابي بلتعه وعويم
ابن ساعده وسلمان الفارسي وابو الدرداء
وبلال مؤذن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وابو رويحه عبد الله ابن عبد الرحمن
الخثعمي رضي الله تعالى عن الجميع هذه
اسماء عظيمه جدا
اكثرها من من جاء فيه الثناء خاص
واكثر اصحاب هذه الاسماء قد بشروا بالجنه
وهم احياء
ومنهم عبد الله بن سلام عبد الله بن سلام
كان حبرا من احبار اليهود دخل في الاسلام
وهو ممن شهد له رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم بالجنه
وهو على قيد الحياه رضي الله تعالى عنه
كثير من الاخوه
يخلط بين المبشرين
العشره
عشره المبشرين بالجنه
والمبشرين المبشرين بالجنه عامه
لو احنا تتبعنا جميع السنن الثابته
الصحيحه
وكذلك ما انزل في القران من ايات تومئ الى
هذه المعاني
نجد ان اسماء الصحابه الذين بشروا بالجنه
اكثار اكثار واكثر من عشره بكثير
فنظرنا الى جميع السنه
لكن
العلماء يخصصون هؤلاء العشره يقولون
العشره المبشرون بالجنه لان النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم جمعهم في حديث واحد حديث
ابن عباس وحديث
سعد بن زيد رضي الله تعالى عنهم يقول
ابو بكر في الجنه وعمر في الجنه وعثمان في
الجنه وعلي بن ابي طالب في الجنه وهكذا
اخذ يذكر هؤلاء العشره وهؤلاء كلهم من
المهاجرين
العلماء حينما تتبعوا ورتبوا فضائل
الصحابه الذي استقر عليه راي اهل السنه
كما نقل شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله في
الواسطيه ذكر ان ترتيب فضائل الصحابه
ابو بكر ثم عمر ثم عثمان ثم علي وهذه
مساله اختلف فيها في قديم قول اهل السنه
ثم استقر رايهم على هذا الترتيب ترتيب
افضليه
الخلفاء الراشدين على ترتيب
خلافتهم هذا الذي عليه اكثر اهل السنه
والذين قالوا بسوى ذلك كادوا ان ينقرضوا
فهذه المساله
هي مساله تتعلق
بالتششيع
تشيع
والعلماء
يفرقون بين
الشيعه والرافضه في فرق بينهما
الان اكثر الناس يطلقون كلمه الشيعه
ويريدون بهم الرافضه
هذه مساله اخرى تختلف
العلماء اجتهدوا في ترتيب افضليه الصحابه
فاتفقوا على ابي بكر ثم عمر هذا شيء متفق
عليه لم يخالف في هذا احد من العلماء لا
من السلف ولا من الخلف
ثم اختلفوا
اختلافا يسيرا بين عثمان وعلي بن ابي طالب
بعض اهل السنه قدم عليا وبعضهم قدم عثمان
لكن هذه مساله في الافضليه ليست مساله في
الخلافه
التشيع ايش هو بصير
التشيع الخفيف يقول عنه العلماء تشيع
الخفيف
هو
مش بس تفضيل عثمان مش بس تفضيل علي على
عثمان بل كذلك
القول بانه
الخلافه كان المفروض تكون ابو بكر ثم عمر
ثم علي وانه خلافه عثمان كانت يعني على حد
عباراتهم فجوه بين الخلافه فجوه في
الخلافه هذا قول مبتدع
وهذا يخرق اجماع الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
واعتبر العلماء هذا القول من الابتداع في
الدين
ما كان في احد من الصحابه ولا من العلماء
ممن قال الخلافه اجت على ترتيب يخالف
الاولى ما في حدا قال هذا الكلام
العلماء اعتبروا صاحب هذا القول من جمله
الشيعه يقولون هذا تشيع خفيف
شيع خفيف يعني
انه الانسان يقول المفروض عثمان ما ولي
الخلاف المفروض تكون ايش تكون الخلافه ابو
بكر ثم عمر ثم علي هكذا يقولون هذا قول
مبتدع لم يقل به احد من ائمه الاسلام
واما الرفض
اجت منها كلمه الرافضه هذول الجماعه ظهروا
بعد
القرن الاول تقريبا في سنه 100
وبدايات العشرين في بدايات سنين 120 بعد
الهجره هذول الرافضه سموا ذلك لانهم رفضوا
خلافه ابي بكر وعمر ورفضوا
خلافه
المسلمين على هذا الترتيب الذي كان فهم
يقولون لا
المفروض
علي رضي الله عنه ولي الخلافه من بدايه
الامر والصحيح يقولون بزعمهم انه الخلافه
نهبت منه هذا اسمه رفض واصحاب هذا القول
رافضه وهذه بدعه مغلظه عند العلماء
لكن شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله وهذا هو الفرق
اصلا الفرق بين التشيع والرفض الرفض بدعه
مغلطه عند العلماء هذا في كلامهم السابق
اما الان
فالشيعه والرافضه تقريبا على السن الناس
صاروا نفس الشيء واكثر ما يعرف يعرفون
الرافضه بكلمه الشيعه
ترتيب
افضليه الصحابه
على ما استقر عليه اجماع اهل السنه كما
نقل شيخ الاسلام في الواسطيه
ابو بكر ثم عمر ثم عثمان ثم علي
ثم العشره
المبشرين بالجنه
ثم
المهاجرين ثم الانصار
ثم اهل اهل بدر قبل المهاجرين والانصار
اهل بدر
هم اهل بيعه العقبه بيعه الرضوان
ثم بشكل عام يعني المهاجرين ثم الانصار ثم
من اسلم بعد الفتح وهكذا
فهؤلاء وهذا الترتيب كان معروفا معهودا في
عهد الصحابه جاء في الصحيح عن ابن عمر
انه قال كنا نقول
ورسول الله حي بيننا ابو بكر ثم عمر ثم
عثمان هكذا كانوا يقولون ابن عمر يقول هذا
ويقول اقرنا على ذلك
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فهذه المؤاخاه هي في كانت بين افضل
الصحابه افضل الصحابه ما منهم احد ارتد عن
الاسلام والعياذ بالله ولا منهم احد نافق
ولا منهم احد
ممن جاء فيه الذم او قاتل الاسلام بعد هذا
وما شابه ذلك هؤلاء هم السابقون الاولون
رضي الله تعالى عنهم
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله وكان يصلي الى
بيت المقدس وقال لجبريل
وددت ان الله صرف وجهي عن قبله اليهود
فقال انما انا عبد فادعو ربك واساله
فجعل يقلب وجهه في السماء يرجو ذلك
فانزل الله عليه قد نرى تقلب وجهك في
السماء
فلنولينك قبله ترضاها
وذلك بعد سته عشر شهرا من مقدمه المدينه
قبل بدر بشهرين
وكان في ذلك
حكم عظيمه
ومحنه للمسلمين والمشركين واليهود
والمنافقين
فاما المسلمون فقالوا امنا به كل من عند
ربنا
وهم الذين هدى الله
ولن ولم تكن كبيره عليهم
وانا لكبيره الا على الذين هدى الله
واما المشركون فقالوا كما رجع الى قبلتنا
يوشك ان يرجع الى ديننا لانه قبله العرب
كانت ايش مكه كان القبله الكعبه يعني
فهم راوا هذا وقالوا رجع لقبلتنا عن قريب
سيرجع الى ديننا
يقول واما اليهود
وما رجع اليها الا انها الحق واما اليهود
فقالوا خالف قبله الانبياء
قبله واما المنافقون فقالوا ما يدري اين
يتوجه يتهكمون والعياذ بالله
ان كانت الاولى حقا فقد تركها وان كانت
الثانيه هي الحق فقد كان على باطل وهذا
كلام ولازم ليس بلازم
والزام ليس بلازم
وكثرت اقاويل السفهاء من الناس وكانت كما
قال الله تعالى وانها لكبيره الا على
الذين هدى الله
وقال تعالى سيقول السفهاء من الناس ما
ولاهم عن قبلتهم التي كانوا عليها فالناس
اختلفوا اختلافا شديدا المسلمون سلموا ولم
تكن عليهم كبيره
وانها لكبيره الا على الذين هدى الله وما
كان الله ليضيع ايمانكم ان الله بالناس لا
رؤوف رحيم
واما المنافقون فقالوا مره يتوجه هيك ومره
يتوجه هيك
هو الان كان يتوجه للكعبه لانه في مكه
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يستطيع
الجمع بين القبلتين صح ولا لا لانه يجعل
الكعب بينه وبين
وبين
الاقصى هو يتوجه للقبله والاقصى معا لكن
لما وصل الى المدينه صاروا عكس
قبله هيك الى المشرق والاقصى الى المغرب
فاضطر
16 شهر انه يصلي الى
بيت المقدس
فكان يقلب وجهه في السماء يعني في الدعاء
يسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوليه قبله
ابيه ابراهيم
والذي رجحه شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله
في كتابه
اقتضاء الصراط المستقيم
مخالفه اهل الجحيم واصحاب الجحيم في هذا
الكتاب العظيم
رجح شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله
ان القبله دائما كانت الى الكعبه هي قبله
الانبياء
لكن اهل الكتاب ابتدعوا بعض الاقاويل وعلى
مر الايام اصبحوا يتوجهون الى بيت المقدس
فهذه كانت محدثه
لكن الله عز وجل اقر هذه يعني مده معينه
من الزمن
وذلك ليمتحن
اليهود والنصارى والمنافقين
وليفرق بين اصحاب الحق واصحاب الباطل
لذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان كان
يقلب وجهه في السماء لانه يريد
يريد ان
يتوجه الى قبله الانبياء
والى قبله ابيه ابراهيم
المنافقون لما شافوا النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم تحولت القبله
قالوا تحول
الى القبله الاولى
فان كانت الكعبه هي القبله لعاد كان على
باطل قبل هيك
وان كان العكس فهو على باطل الان وهذا
كلام باطل في نفسه ليش
لان هذا حكم حكم فقهي حكم عملي يقبل
الناسخ صح ولا لا في نسخ الله عز وجل يامر
بشيء ويكون هذا الشيء مناسب في فتره معينه
ثم ينسخ ذلك القول
وهذا باجماع العلماء اجماع علماء اهل
السنه
انه النسخ مش بس جائز بل واقع في القران
وواقع في سنه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ببراهين لا ترد
الله عز وجل يقول ما ننسخ من ايه او ننسها
ناتي بخير منها او مثلها
سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء الله
وهلم جره
ورايت
في هذه الايام اخر عشر 15 سنه
ظهرت
اقوال بين كثير من عامه المسلمين
يعني
يرددون شبهات
واقوال
الجهميه والمعتزله للجماعات اللي كانوا
زمان البدع اللي دفنوها العلماء زمان بعض
الناس بعثوا هذه الشبهات والقوا بين الناس
فانتشر بين الناس انه النسخ لا يجوز في
القران مستحيل يبقى في شيء اسمه نسخ وهذا
قول اليهود ليس قول المسلمين
المسلمون
يثبتون من الصحابه وانت وانت نازل كلهم
كلام الصحابي مليان بالقول بالناسخ وذكر
الايات المنسوخه وما شابه ذلك
فلله عز وجل يذكر النسخ ايه ويذكر ايه
بعدها مباشره هي تنسخ اختها
نسخ في الاحكام الفقهيه فيها احكام
العمليه ما فيها مانع
المشكله النسخ في في الاخبار هذا ليس
واقعا باجماع العلماء
يعني الله عز وجل ينزل حكم شرعي هذا حلال
ثم يحرم او العكس او توجهوا الى بيت
المقدس وينسخ هذا بالتوجه الى
الكعبه فش مشكله هذه اعمال فقهيه
لكن المشكله وين بتكون اذا انزل الله خبرا
انه هكذا الحق
ثم ينزل بعد ذلك يكذب هذا الخبر الاول هذا
ليس واقعا في القران ولا في السنه
والله عز وجل نفى ذلك عن كتابه واعتبره
نقصا
وقال
ولو كان من عند غير الله لوجدوا فيه
اختلافا كثيرا
فهذا ما في نسخ في الاخبار الخبر اما صادق
او كاذب ما في
لكن الاحكام فيها شيء مستحب وشيء محرم
وشيء مباح وشيء ما في مشكله
والقول بخلاف ذلك قول واه باطل ومن قول من
اقوال اهل البدع في الاسلام
قولون يعني النسخ مستحيل يكون في القران
مستحيل في الاحكام
الفقهيه وهذا كلام باطل واللي بده يحكي
هذا الخول بده يلوي
النصوص
واعناقلص النصوص يعني عشرات النصوص بده
يلويها وبده
يشكلبها عشان يجعلها تتركب على بعضها هذه
المقوله
على كل حال يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله
وكانت محنه من الله ليرى من يتبع الرسول
ممن ينقلب على عقبيه ولما كان شان القبله
عظيما وطا سبحانه قبلها امر النسخ
وقدرته عليه ما ننسخ قصده في ترتيب الايات
في سوره البقره هو يقول لما كانت مساله
القبله مساله عظيمه وطا ذلك بتمهيد
وقال ما ننسخ من ايه او ننسها ناتي بخير
منها او مثلها الم تعلم ان الله على كل
شيء قدير وانه ياتي بخير من المنسوخ او
مثله ثم عقبه بالتوبيخ لمن تعنت على رسوله
ولم ينقض له ثم ذكر اختلاف اليهود
والنصارى وشهاده بعضهم على بعض بانهم
ليسوا على شيء وقالت اليهود ليست النصارى
على شيء وقالت النصارى ليست اليهود على
شيء وهم يتلون الكتاب
وحذر عباده من موافقتهم واتباع اهوائهم ثم
ذكر كفرهم به وقولهم ان له ولدا سبحانه
وتعالى
وقالوا اتخذ الله ولدا سبحانه ثم اخبر ان
له المشرق والمغرب فاينما
ولا عباده
فاينما ولا عباده وجوههم فثم وجهه وهو
الواسع العليم
فلعظمته وسعته واحاطته اينما توجه العبد
فثم وجه الله ثم اخبر انه لا يسال رسوله
عن اصحاب الجحيم الذين لا يتابعونه
ثم اخبره ان اهل الكتاب لن يرضوا عنه حتى
يتبع ملتهم ثم ذكر اهل الكتاب نعمته عليهم
وخوفهم باسه ثم ذكر خليله باني بيته واثنى
عليه واخبر انه جعله اماما للناس ثم ذكر
بيته الحرام وبناء خليله له وفي ضمن هذا
ان ان بانيه كما هو امام للناس فكذلك
البيت الذي بناه امام لهم
ثم اخبر انه لا يرغب عن مله هذا الامام
الا اسفه الناس ثم امر عباده ان ياتموا به
ويؤمنوا بما انزل اليه والى النبيين ثم رد
على من قال ان ابراهيم واهله كانوا هدى او
نصارى وجعل هذا كله توطئه بين يدي تحويل
القبله واكد سبحانه الامر مره بعد مره
وامر به حيث كان رسوله
ومن حيث خرج
الى هنا نكتفي بهذا القدر
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد